all right
true
mic check mic check mic check ladies and
Gentlemen people of the internet check
check one two
hello
all right everybody we are live people
of the internet retro wrecking tour here
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell and the the tour
continues I mean this is just like a
week really two weeks I feel like of
Hogwarts Legacy Harry Potter Wizarding
World streams so this is our last uh
Tuesday stream guys before the release
of the game I still can't believe it so
I was like we gotta do something special
gotta do something fun so thanks to all
of these folks joining me tonight we'll
just start here wizard PhD
right away
I
am James James just realizing that we're
alive we're live James
what's water I'm not getting ready for
it
James do you know how it is once you got
the countdown rolling it's like it's on
yeah
Holy Ghost I am problematic from Wizard
PhD
um I cover Hogwarts Legacy do live
streams do some video and I got to
experience the game with all these
lovely people some of whom I met for the
first time some of whom I've known for
quite a long time so happy to be here
thank you thank you and James good thing
you didn't spill the beans on that like
third showcase that oh wait wait I mean
uh uh man I was about to go into yo this
is what Jason go pick you guys the
greatest August Legacy cotton and uh
today I am so honored to be amongst
These Fine human beings and uh just
talking about the hype that is Hogwarts
Legacy and a little bit about us so
thanks retro yeah man thanks for joining
me and we'll we'll get to your you've
you've had a lot of travels lately we'll
get to that in a second Ben you're up
next good to see you again Ben welcome
Hey thank you for having me retro I
think it's the first time actually being
on your channel I think so yeah yeah I
appreciate it I'm Ben snow I cover
Hogwarts Legacy I've been covering for
like two years and uh yeah I enjoy on
being here thank you so much
and then finally we have Miranda so
Miranda and I met along with James at
the
um Hands-On session of Hogwarts Legacy
what feels like yesterday still but I
guess it's almost two weeks ago now so
Miranda thank you for coming on
thank you for having me yeah time flies
so
um yeah so I am Miranda or also known as
the Miranda lorian and then depending on
the time of day I am also known as
Miranda
I cover a lot of gaming stuff I pretty
much do a lot of Let's Plays
playthroughs I am obsessed with video
games I also like to emphasize like Good
Vibes video games all that good stuff
but I will be covering Hogwarts Legacy
in my playthrough for a long time
because this game for me has been highly
anticipated since I can remember so this
was kind of a dream come true when this
was announced nice again thank you yeah
well thank you all for being here and
thank you all in the chat here I already
see we got a bunch of new subscribers we
got super chats going we got gifted
memberships I saw elwin and uh we also
had a donation let's see Ravenclaw
Tyrell thank you guys so much so we are
going to uh obviously there's been a lot
of these streams lately so I was talking
to the folks beforehand like what can we
do to make this you know a little bit
different we'll be happy to answer any
of your questions so everybody here
tonight we all play the game about a
week and a half ago so if y'all have any
questions on that of course we'd love to
answer them but I thought with this
being really the last chance before the
launch of the game well at least for me
I mean you guys you guys may have other
stuff planned the rest of the week but
for me this is like my last live stream
before
the game is out and I just wanted to
like take a step back and just kind of
reflect for a little bit because I was
thinking I was like this game I almost
made the title Hogwarts Legacy changed
my life I was like yeah that's people
say to clickbaity but it legitimately I
think we can all say maybe not in the
case of James and Lynette you guys have
met before this but the rest of us the
only reason we met the only reason we've
had any interactions at all is is
because of this game which blows my mind
at some point in our history on YouTube
we decided let's make a video about
Hogwarts Legacy and then it has it's LED
here so I just wanted to talk about this
this crazy journey and how we ended up
here and James I mean maybe you could
start because you well you and Lynette
both you covered Wizards unite and then
there were the rumors of this game like
is it real is it not real there was also
the magic awaken so it's like like when
did you decide like what was the moment
you're like Hogwarts Legacy I need to
I'm gonna make some videos about that
um well we were always going to when we
first found out which is a story in and
of itself uh we were actually having a
Wizarding Wednesday in September 2020
and uh uh chat just goes crazy they're
making a Harry Potter game they're
making a Harry Potter game it's on right
now and I'm just like what are you
talking about so we interrupt our live
stream cut to that and we just start
losing our bodies music and everything
yes it got kind of very strike but we
didn't care
um so after that we were just like yo we
gotta we gotta cover this game we gotta
talk about this game but we'll talk
about it you know once it gets close to
the release and then of course uh that
got delayed and then the game Harry
Potter Wizards unite which is the game
we were covering got uh got um it's
uh so once that's like once we knew that
was going to happen I slowly started uh
making content for uh Hogwarts Legacy
and
um trying to get the algorithm to
recognize our Channel as a Hogwarts it
takes a little bit it does it does so
yeah that was kind of like how how we
started but what about you guys
yeah Lynette we'll just jump to you
since you uh also had some wizard you
Wizards unite content yeah yeah so for
those y'all who are unfair
on Harry Potter wizard
you know where it was made by Niantic
the people who made Pokemon go so
um a big piece of uh expecto go and
wizard PhD content was out in the world
in the community with people which of
course got interrupted uh when
everything shut down yeah so uh but
backing up a little bit so I'm pretty
sure James so James and I met like a
long time ago I want to say like late
2017 early 2018 maybe early 2018. I
don't know but when those initial leaks
came out for Hogwarts Legacy which it
wasn't named Hogwarts Legacy right um
there were a group of us if you've ever
heard me say the word or James say the
word Wu tuber or yeah yeah those are
Wizards unite YouTubers and we had met
um before launch similar to this where
like we were covering the game and then
got connected with each other because
content creation is such a unique
experience that it was nice to talk to
other people who understood what it felt
like to be putting your yourself online
every single week and just trying to
figure out how to navigate the space
given that none of us really had been
content creators before yep so I
remember when the leaks came out because
we were all chatting with each other on
Discord and being like did you see this
did you see this and also being mindful
of like you know we don't want to
position ourselves in a particular way
we want to make sure that we have we
have elements of trust of like uh
building a partnership with WB Games and
so like we had seen the original leaks
but we didn't really cover it right
James says
we had very intense discussions about
that and then uh same thing so
um yeah Wizarding Wednesday was going on
I was I think I was like napping or
something and then like my phone started
going off because somebody dm'd me and
this was back when I had no I don't have
notifications pushed on my phone but
this was back then you know 2020
whatever and it was just like you need
to see this right now and it was only
and the PlayStation thing was still
running live and it was like here's the
time stamp go back and watch this and
immediately I made a reaction to that uh
reveal trailer and I also was like
sleuthing everything I followed all of
them on social I think I was that
initial video if you look you'll see how
many subscribers Hogwarts likes that
YouTube had at the time when I
subscribed to them went into their
Discord and made like an FAQ so that was
my first Hogwarts Legacy video and then
I was just like okay I don't know
anything else about this game so I I
didn't really pick it back up until
later on when Wizardry night was ending
and starting to make more dedicated
Hogwarts Legacy content uh but yeah I
started with Harry Potter wow nice
that's awesome and Ben what about you
was your first was it the reaction was
it the reaction video no actually I
think no the very first Hogwarts video
was a delay a
uh when when it got first delayed the
delay so long ago now that's crazy yeah
um I watched the reveal trailer though I
I watched Alex podcast now for the
longest time talking about the league
and I was like oh cool that's cool I
wanna I want that but it was like it was
hanging on a thread I couldn't believe
that now I would care about me not a
Harry Potter game no one no like because
at that time we had only Hogwarts
mystery and wizards unite yeah that I
tried a little bit and then stopped
using
um and yeah I just kind of nah nah and
then when it got revealed I was watching
that showcase not for Hogwarts Legacy or
I thought it was I was watching for God
of War like okay I'm gonna see yeah that
was the reason and then all of a sudden
it was insane I was screaming so loud
yeah it was like yeah it was crazy and
then I I don't know what I was doing
with my life at that time but then uh I
kind of decided okay I wanna I think I
wanna cover this I think I wanna talk
about this game you know I saw at that
time mostly was
Alex talking about it and I think you
retro appeared I think I started seeing
you maybe
and then I was like okay I I know about
this this is the Lord I want to talk
about it too because no one around me
talked about how Harry Potter at all
there was no one to to communicate with
anyone so I was like I want to talk
about this I want to share my opinion
and then that's how I started
um and actually like through this time
it kind of helped me in the way I I I
did talk about this with Alan too when
we met that you know this it like that
was really dark times for me and uh I
wanted to focus on something different
and I really glad I started doing
YouTube because it really kept me going
for something there was something that I
was looking forward to and distracting
myself so it you know Hogwarts Legacy in
general has a really special heart
uh it does has a special place in my
heart that's what I was trying to say
well I I thought you me like even the
even the game itself like I feel like
has heart and the people behind it now
that we've met them the passion for it
um I think we may have lost some Miranda
we'll see if we can get her back in here
but guys thank you for all let's see
we've had so many new subscribers so
many people renewing their memberships
uh Nico said uh with a super chat
amazing to see you all together thanks
thank you for bringing everyone together
to make this community a fun welcoming
place for all thank you Nico and then we
had a this might be a channel record
right for you retro you got
1200 oh let's go I didn't I didn't even
I haven't even been looking at the
number people hadn't even been looking
yeah thank you guys for being here and
hanging out man we've been doing this
and I mean honestly I gotta give props
to James I mean James being in James's
live streams Wizarding Wednesdays that's
that's what made me realize like dude I
gotta start doing uh I gotta start doing
live streams again like that that
Community aspect
um see if I can get Miranda added oh it
says device not connected let's see if
we can get her back in here shortly but
um no I don't want to ban her don't
Banner maybe it'll let her join back in
we'll try again here in a second but
yeah like seeing that that sense of
community and just like the theorizing
when James would have he was always so
prepared dude so prepared James
organized he's got his list of topics
five minutes in it's all out the window
it just like completely down this Rabbit
Hole of Merlin and Morgana which I've
I've been told to ask you James by by
some of the people in my community they
wanted me to ask like even now are you
still
a week out here are you feeling
confident are you still feeling
confident about the theories
um I'm not gonna lie like every trailer
and stuff I get I'm just like uh-oh
like oh but but I said it last week and
I'm gonna say it this week I am
remaining on this hill that Merlin is
going to play a huge role whether as a
guy who's going to guide us with ancient
magic or possibly daddy Merlin
he wrote Daddy Merlin is real on my
signature board yeah I want to keep you
to that yes I did so uh yeah I I'm still
holding strong and I would die on this
hill if I'm wrong yo I will look into
the camera and say the boy James over
expect to go was wrong about rarely but
you know I'm staying up here until said
otherwise so yeah I gotcha all right it
looks like we got yeah we got Miranda
back sorry about that I don't know what
happened
oh and now even now mine's kind of doing
this weird uh flickering here but
technology we'll see I think we're good
now but um so Miranda we're about to get
to you you were making Let's Play videos
and then what what was it when you saw
the Hogwarts Legacy trailer that you
were like I need to react to this or I
want to react to this because that was
that was the first video I saw you when
I first met you and you said your
channel name I was like
I've seen your thumbnail I know I've
seen your thumbnail and it was from that
video it was from your reaction video
yeah
um I would say everything really started
off
it off reaction video and it's kind of
funny because that day I think I was
just having a day so like there was
there was a part of me where I almost
didn't make that video I don't know what
it was but just something deep down was
like just make this video just check out
this trailer you're gonna love it so I
did
um made a reaction video of it uploaded
it and it it it it just kind of took on
a life of its own like a lot of people
are watching it there's like great
feedback and it was really cool to see
the entire like Wizarding World
Community kind of come together in the
comment section just saying how excited
they were for this game so that was like
for me that was my Telltale sign I was
like yes you know this there's something
here and I think this this game has a
lot like around it and it could be a
really good thing for a lot of people so
it just for me that's kind of what
sparked the excitement
so and I think that maybe that's the
video that kind of led me to possibly
going to La and like meeting all of you
guys so I'm extremely grateful and very
glad that I decided to put up that video
so yeah when I saw your face I was like
wait a second I've seen this person
before just like recommended by exactly
what I said yeah
YouTube's crazy I can't believe like
what it can do for people you know yeah
I think the the private chats are
showing too on screen just just FYI so
you guys know but yeah thanks retro did
you say you don't put anything in there
yeah yeah
um Okay so
Ben
you're or actually James I wanted to
talk about the um
I wanted to ask you guys maybe some of
your favorite moments from the past two
two and a half years and I'm putting you
on the spot so I'll I'll give mine first
whether it's like you're one of your
favorite videos or somebody else's video
that you just absolutely were like one
of like these Community moments you know
like that we we talk about as a group
because for me
I will never forget the moment when they
announced you were doing a gameplay
showcase my
my jaw was like on the floor like
because we had never seen anything like
that and I don't know that I've ever
seen another developer do anything quite
like that to really get into the
community speaking of I think I saw some
people saying hi to Chandler I don't
know if Chandler if Chandler's actually
here what's oh yeah I see what's up
seeing a text exchange on social we yeah
it was so perfect yeah yeah but yeah so
yeah we should get to that we should get
to when we uh it seems like a new
trailer's on the way guys but yeah we'll
talk about that here in a second but
when they made that showcase
announcement I was just like they get it
man they get it they're yeah they've
gotten someone who is just such a great
representation of this community I mean
I'm not saying anything I haven't
already told James in private guys but
I'll tell him in front of you all too
and like like the fact that something
like that was even possible my jaw was
on the floor and then of course the
whole showcase happened and it was it
was great and then you know we had been
as well it's just like we've had so many
of these great Community moments
throughout like so many great videos
have been made on this game but that one
for me so I don't know Lynette if you
want to go next or just some of your
favorite favorite moments from the past
daddy Merlin came as a result of this
whole thing I don't need to talk about
it if you know you know if you don't
then come find out
um I would say so my favorite videos are
the reaction videos honestly
um just in general as as just I love
seeing people react especially because I
know I can be super extra so I just find
joy that other people can be super extra
as well
um but I will say and I've already
praised Ben in La I will say that I do
get jealous of your like some of your
big videos like the highly produced the
things where you're like when you made
you recreated the robe and you did that
whole thing like that all of that stuff
just makes me want to be a better
content creator so I mean I'm just I've
just gotta praise you again I love
everyone's content and I love seeing
different things that push me to be like
Oh I'm gonna learn how to do that or
that was a good like creative choice
right there and so it's just this
continuing Evolution honestly and
especially if you looked at the last
five years of my content please don't go
back as far
but like I I see it in myself of like oh
I've grown such a a lot and it's because
of being connected to other creative
people so I think that's really fun well
I came I mean just like after that whole
La trip I mean such a short trip but I
came away from that so energized like
ready to just inspired by every single
one of you and seeing like that this is
all it's something bigger I mean bigger
than even bigger than Hogwarts like just
this this idea of community and making
these friendships it's it's it really is
I mean it's yeah I'm not gonna get
emotional but like that's that's how I
feel about it I mean it's just so I get
so excited I mean I came away from that
I mean James and Miranda and I quite
literally talked the entire day about
this game YouTube content strategy and
just like and then after it was done I
was like okay I'm ready to I'm ready to
do more I'm ready yeah yeah sorry didn't
mean to jump in I know I asked you all
to answer the question but you should
answer questions
we'll jump to bin now Ben what's some of
your either favorite videos or just
favorite moments from the past uh two
and a half years or so here
um it's hard to piece together because
the past couple of years for me was just
such a you know it's it's different it's
just it's kind of a mush I really the
Highlight definitely was when the state
of play came in it was it was even I I
saw the fear in the community that the
game is canceled or something like that
and then that old Joy of everyone just
seeing what this is that how really like
the the developers really listened to
the desires of the fans
we wanted and like that showcase
answered all those questions and it was
mind-blowing and how everyone just you
know flipped and then it became like the
the views went crazy
yeah no more leaks too no more leaks yes
there were allowing leaks for a long
time so yeah oh my goodness we got the
Wizarding World here in the chat
our favorite moment of the day is
watching this stream I see a check mark
so I'm assuming it's legit Wizarding
World what is up
thank you for being here
we are not worthy
we got Chandler in the house now
Wizarding world's here man oh my God
next oh no I'm waiting I'm waiting for
uh Daniel Radcliffe but I'm sorry baby
oh my God
I think also like going to you know
meeting actually developers during the
Salt Lake trip it was just it wasn't
real and it's like
like as I said
um I I was most for most of my life I
was kind of a loner and uh I didn't have
people to talk about games too much dude
yeah or Harry Potter and just finding
that Community where I I can now sit and
talk for hours about a video game and
people on the other side actually care
about that video game that's so unique
and it just I I you know I so often find
myself
uh in these moments just kind of
cherishing this just the chat the the
communication and when we were meeting
each other uh we were all together
chatting about as you said YouTube or
the game just conversations I would just
literally really cherishing those simple
moments yes just making kind of you know
memory pictures so to say yeah yeah and
Hogwarts Legacy in the chat too no
pressure guys like the whole the whole
what Wizarding World
that
[Laughter]
this weekend I can't wait they're really
comfortable too I don't know if anybody
caught caught what I'm rocking tonight
your Christmas present yeah this is my
Christmas present for my wife I was like
oh this is just I gotta get the r you
know
Miranda how about you I know you had
hearing you talk from your Vlog you just
had such a great experience on the trip
and
if you want to share your special story
about what happened while we were in the
park something that really kind of
validated and made you not to put you on
this I'll tell it if you want so no it's
okay it's okay I just I haven't like
thought about it in a couple days so
sometimes when I remember it it's just
like the the initial shock all over
again yeah also is this thing on I know
like it is yeah
thanks a lot okay anyway yeah no the the
trip itself was so extremely special to
me because well number one I think I
said this yesterday but I showed up as a
complete stranger like with all of you I
didn't know any of you guys so you know
showing up like that and then leaving
feeling like I have made like such a
solid group of friends where now I can
DM you guys and we can do talks like
this and help podcasts just sit and
chill in Discord is really really cool
but going to but going back to what you
mentioned earlier like the the cool
thing to happen and so I've been doing
content online or just putting myself
out there online for since 2017. so it's
been a long time and I'd never really
expected anything like this to happen
but retro and I were walking around
um Universal Studios it specifically in
Harry Potter World which is even more
meaningful considering everything that
was like why we were there and
everything and all of a sudden this
person walks up to me and they're like
are you the Miranda lorian and I just
was like blank full blank I was like
what'd you say excuse me like did you
yes I don't know I feel like I'm the one
who fan girl but it was um it was just
really really exciting to like be
recognized
um and just be told that like people
enjoy the content that you put out there
because sometimes I put things out there
thinking that it's just for me I'm just
talking to myself and nobody's really
gonna watch it so it was an extremely
humbling humbling even reference like
specific he was like I love how you
talked about this and when you got that
game so it's like he wasn't just like
yeah he hadn't just seen her and I mean
he really like knew the content and I
just kind of stepped back and was like
I'm just gonna let like let this happen
it was so great is this the first time
like that was the first time and you
just looked at me you're like I'm so
glad I got to it yeah it was magical pun
intended all the way and that yeah it
was just insane too that it happened in
Harry Potter World yeah so that was
crazy exactly all right James bring it
home bring it home I know you got some
epic moments from these past two and a
half years man uh
honestly the first one would have been
the Showcase yeah if it wasn't for LA
um
the difference between the two we both
kind of got like a peek behind the
curtain you know with each event and you
know yeah I'm hosting and like this is
the first one but I was mostly nervous
because this was the first one this was
a big deal this was their first one and
so for Avalanche software this was a big
deal for them they've been planning for
a long time
um I've known about it for months you
know before I was even there that you
kept that so long yeah so I had to play
koi for a while
um but at the same time
is not sharing you're not sharing that
experience like you are at a bla event
and I think that was the big part for me
because retro you talked about like our
Wizarding Wednesdays I learned playing
Harry Potter Wizards unite the power of
connection especially during 2020 and
you couldn't go outside with a game that
encourages you to go outside and we had
to figure out how to stay connected
despite not being able to do it in real
life and I appreciate that even more now
after the fact and so getting to LA and
then having not so much the same
experience but an experience with this
game with others who are covering the
game and sharing your insights and
passions and hopes and dreams alongside
the same kind of pathway with content
created I'm like man you can't replicate
that man like Jake is clutch man and
like there's a Vibe there's an energy
there's a it's just an excitement that
comes from that and not only like
meeting the devs and Chandler Eric you
know Alan Boston and everybody else no
it's not even that it's just other
people like yourselves like you guys who
you've only seen just via text in chat
and maybe sometimes with podcasts now
when we all come together and so that
was magical man and then to cap it off
at Universal a place where I met Lynette
met Kellen four years ago met Peter over
the product collector four years ago
covering the game as we were like just
dipping our toes in the content Creation
with 200 subscribers like it just came
full circle and what Peter said like yo
James like I'm so proud of you like
Lynette said it takes you back to where
you started and now coming forward like
we're at 2200 subscribers I mean 22 000
subscribers whatever like yeah thousands
are like is that zero yeah but I mean
you just appreciate the journey and I
will always say this like you know
wherever I am at five years from now you
know I would love to take this full time
we'll see what happens but yo this
journey I can tell my kids like bro like
go after it go see what happens and
you'll never know you might meet people
who change your lives and so that's what
this game has done this so it has
Community has continued to do and I
cannot wait to see what happens when the
game releases yeah for sure oh man I
just get excited to listen to all of you
man it's like what's crazy to me is that
I mean you the two of you over here you
all knew each other but the rest of us
we hadn't met in person before and
Miranda talked about this in her uh one
of her videos it's just like
I just felt like we'd known each other
for a long time you know there was no
awkwardness of like hey it was just like
a little bit nervous but then we're
right into like James I just I just
hugged James
had the big smile on his face you know
and then we're just following him as he
checked it oh you weren't there but that
first night me Ben Breda the pink
Ravenclaw were literally Paparazzi
filming him as he was checking in and
I'm just there like oh my God come on
James I turn around for the check out
this I just see cameras like right here
I'm just like from three people I was
like I know you guys like we've met
before like I know who you are not dead
so much but like
what are you doing
James has got the Vlog thing down dude
he hopped in the back of an Uber he's
like yo what's your boy James I'm like
dude I got a professional I gotta watch
I gotta learn from this wizard I even
shared my Vlog
recorded a bunch all right so we got
Hogwarts Legacy Chandler Wizarding World
in the house they just teased something
tonight guys I think we all saw it
before we hopped on so it seems like
seems like we might be getting a trailer
later this week I don't know their
Chandler was saying it was another
League
not that there's been any of those
We're not gonna talk about those no no
but yeah so I mean I would assume this
will be the final trailer that we get
yeah for the launch of the game what are
you guys hoping to see
um as we because we we've played a
little bit of the game we've had a taste
of it now
what does this last one need to show we
haven't seen I mean so far they've done
I think it was you Ben who was talking
about maybe last night when we were on
with Lynette how they've done such a I
would say like a unique job with the
marketing of like you have these
gameplay showcases then you have asmrs
then you have like really cinematic
trailers then you've got the show the um
state of play where you're really diving
in it's just been so fun to kind of
watch all the different styles so what
do you guys think we're gonna see in
this last one what would you like to see
in this in this last one here I don't
need to be short Merlin Merlin of course
one shot yeah go ahead yeah um statue I
mean you're right after that that's like
from you know after watching the music
video and stuff like that I'm like I
don't know what to expect I don't know
what to expect but as what it is in the
little tease clip it says launch trailer
now I'm thinking okay if it is a launch
trailer it's sort of I believe it will
summarize everything that Hogwarts
Legacy is
um so I don't know it's like there's a
part where I want to see but
um I feel like I'm just excited to see
what they're gonna put up because
because they've been so creative with
every trailer like this owl suffering so
much
the poor thing uh he's a hero he needs a
he needs the men special mention that
out but uh it's such a unique
storytelling point so I'm excited to see
what they're gonna show but for me
more fire tornadoes please
yes yes
always
I still don't even know how you got
because it was the enemies who cast the
fire I'm sorry I'm sorry no no
Battle of Hogwarts
no way I still believe I still believe
one man can release I think so yes all
right tornado I think it's a thing I
think I think it will happen I think it
will happen I don't know if they'll show
it but I think that's gonna happen right
that would be clutch though all right so
we also got another all right I told you
guys I meant to do this at the beginning
completely forgot but I'm gonna send you
guys a message wait my phone's waiting
for you all right so in our in our group
message on Twitter this is our Buddy Joe
Mack I've got presents worked on this
yes thank you
to do it thank God I'm gonna pull it up
here on screen for everyone you guys
enjoy this video
because it literally looks like that cat
all right hold on I gotta pull it up for
everybody else now let's see
there we go
everybody
yep oh my God so that was a new little
clip they showed last night and I think
was it your idea Lynette you're like oh
my goodness we've gotta have we need
that into a meme with the cat I love
this it's like my favorite form of like
Media communication that just you have
something for everything you but there's
like skill to it like you have to
communicate something in a very compact
way in this visual format and I just I
love it so much
I mean
I love the the emotion portrayed in its
face yes
like the way he cut off that clip it
seems like the hippogriff wasn't happy
with with the character approach him
that was a fight they got hurt like
Malfoy did I told Joe
um in a Wizarding Wednesday I think like
right after the Showcase was revealed I
was like bruh like I was talking to the
devs in the lunchroom and a couple of
them have referenced your memes that
you've posted I'm just saying I'm just
saying and like right he's known he is
known worldwide like does not miss
well talking about yesterday's stream
with Lynette uh James where were you
a good segue I forgot about that too see
this is how it is when we get together I
was like I don't need a script we can
like just go dude wait where are you sir
what is this setting up what Segway are
we talking about what are you talking
about share with the class
Alibi please I saw he tweeted the
picture at Wizarding World and Miranda's
like what did you tweet it or you're
like what question mark question mark
question mark we were just there I know
I was so confused I was genuinely
confused
if you must know I was there for a
friend's wedding I'm part of a podcast
group African nerds media and uh they
had a wedding in Orlando and the
bachelor and bachelorette party was at
Universal Studios at Wizarding World of
Harry Potter my actual first time
visiting that location and so that's why
I was there how was diagonally isn't it
oh my gosh oh my gosh I haven't been
there I haven't been since they added
diagonal either I I loved it I loved la
I love Universal Burbank wherever the
asaps but it's nothing compared to the
one in Orlando one is so much bigger in
Diagon Alley oh my gosh like they yeah
every detail every store like I went
into green guts I have pictures and you
just see the scale and stuff
oh yeah oh yeah yeah but
um yeah it's it's yeah I didn't want is
amazing so I encourage everybody that's
a bucket list for any uh Wizard World
fans and you know uh Chandler was there
too we gotta meet there
yeah yeah yes please we got a Super Chat
Finn has a great idea they should drop
the trailer right now so the community
can enjoy it together
oh man and then we have this red tape
yeah
Carlos said it would be great in a
future game we are in our seventh year I
made a first year Dumbledore so we've
all been trying to figure out the dates
since this whole chuddly Cannon poster
thing it's not 1980 anyway listen or
anytime
it's late 1800s in every single thing
and sticky published in text it says
late 1800s and I've said over and over
I'm like why is it say this if there's
you know not a specific date what's
going on here yeah yeah they're just
going vague for that reason just like no
one knows what year this is ever maybe
they're never gonna even say it in the
game see they learned because they did
that first trailer and we're like Zoom
yeah there's when it starts that's it
it's done it's seals all the theories
will forever be crafted based on this
date and they're like oh actually nah I
don't think it is anymore man yeah
convinced either so but to this to this
super chat's point I mean if it gets
pushed any later that gets closer to our
boy Albus yeah and yeah that is maybe
that is to your point Lynette like if
they won or was it Ben that said maybe
they're just going vague and not
actually giving the dates like they
don't want it to get into Dumbledore
territory because if Dumbledore gets in
then it's like it's not your story
anymore right right then it's a little
bit and then we had the ore division
with a super chat a Full House of these
amazing creators what more can we ask
for all of you are amazing have a great
stream one week guys one week or
division thank you thank you for the
support and guys if I've missed any I
apologize when I get to talking to these
folks I'm just like okay I'm just like
in the zone so thank you all so much
look like we had pineapple cheers with
the Super Chat uh glad you all got to
experiences together Ben I was only able
to get my girlfriend to watch Hogwarts
content because you can quote ride a
horsey your energy was amazing
I love that one and Chandler with some
clarification remember we've said that
we don't want known characters to
overshadow your story
there we go thank you thank you Chandler
Chandler jumping in it's definitely
before what 92 right because you have to
be 10 or 11 when you start yeah
81 yeah and you're right it's been there
92. yeah yeah you're right treasure like
and like you said if Dumbledore comes in
that's it he is then the main everyone
was going to be wondering about not
themselves
yeah yeah yeah
and then uh Carlo is uh this was a thing
from last night Ben was not a big fan of
the badger Carlo is like dude come on
let's see
he said back in South Africa they are
best avoided they are tenacious if they
want to attack
okay you missed it James last night
I hate in the bedroom he was on his
soapbox about it
like hey no joke
you've got a lion you got an eagle a
snake and then you get it like a beaver
that just sits there and does nothing
seriously
all right here we go here I'm just gonna
sit there right now
the other two hufflepuffs are gonna
fight you I know I'm just like let this
happen I'm right next door dude like
let's go no I I got explained now I'm
like I need to reevaluate my
understanding of badgers I understand
maybe I wasn't uninformed they just seem
like just little little hamsters or
something so
yeah but today today something has
changed
I did a quiz
it yes no is it different yes it is I
was watching it's Gryffindor
oh God
I don't even know you anymore
I am that Hufflepuff that chose to no
I'm that Gryffindor that chose to be you
had the choice
chose Gryffindor instead of Slytherin I
chose Hufflepuff instead of Gryffindor
but but in the thing the percentage was
like on the third place it was first
percentage was Gryffindor then Ravenclaw
no I don't even know you anymore I don't
even know that's what I told you see
sometimes I I'm mostly Hufflepuff but I
tend to slip into Gryffindor Miranda
have you posted your video yet I don't
want to get I don't want to give it away
because I know you were doing the same
thing
it's ready it's like it's uh rendered
it's all good to go I just need to
upload it but yeah okay
oh that that quiz got philosophical they
were asking some like deep dive
questions I was like I really had to sit
there and think
let's get my results
I don't know if James will be able to
handle it if he loses another Hufflepuff
he will
I don't I don't know any of you guys
anymore
right before the game comes out we're
doing tests what is happening
I'm done I'm still a Hufflepuff I'm the
same person you know me so he had the
choice James yes he's always chosen
Hufflepuff yeah
but here's the thing y'all after the
game launches I will be having
individual streams with you getting to
know you specifically where we will
Resort you in houses in a very special
different way it's gonna be a lot of fun
so it's going to be kind of get to know
the creators type of streams hey I like
it I just have to shout out this uh we
got a couple more Super chats Morgan
from old oak with a 20 Super Chat said I
have terminal liver disease and I'm
going to Wizarding World in Orlando in
September my wish I could meet you all
there this is my bucket list oh my
goodness
oh my gosh if you're going September 1st
I gotta I gotta be there then yeah back
to Hogwarts day if we're if you're going
on September 1st
I mean we've been saying that we need to
do meet up again because it wasn't long
enough that was our only problem
I saw you just for a couple of hours
yeah
I actually met oh wait you guys never
got to meet no I didn't mean
yeah I only saw you in photos yeah now
keep in mind also speaking of back to
Hogwarts day during that event where uh
Chandler blew the roof off with that
Slytherin entrance
um The Wizard World did also reveal
they're doing a Wizarding World Fan Fest
or something like that in the United
States they haven't said where yet but
they haven't said where and they haven't
said the time they just know 2023
Wizarding World Fan Fest if you remember
that trailer it had like a Vibes of uh
World Cup quidditch World Cup type
situation so
um that could be a place where everybody
including chat where we all could just
come together and meet yes yes so keep
that in mind absolutely was it in World
Coachella totally yes yes yes yes but
more like more
chill yeah yeah yeah yeah
all seriousness Morgan that that means a
lot to all of us I know and wishing you
all the best hope you get to have a
fantastic trip and hey if we if we can
make it happen I would certainly love to
do that uh we also had dream and plays
games with the Super Chat haven't been
this excited for a game in a while now
just keep looking at the timer on my
PlayStation yep we know that feeling uh
Carla dude Carlo is going all in on
these Badgers another fun fact from a
South African lions have been killed by
Badgers
watch out Gryffindor I know I'm scared
now yo they yo they're Pharaoh yo don't
attack them like we're Loyals are like
same thing that's why it works for me I
just gotta get to know the the fair the
animal more yeah my goodness you guys
are these super chats Johnny
gryffindor's Dark Wolf I love you all
but to James and retro I've dealt with
some heavy life changes like losing my
mom and the two of you in the
communities that support you have helped
through it all I can't express how much
I appreciate it Johnny dude thank you so
much man Johnny always showing love on
Twitter on YouTube very sorry to hear
that you lost your mom and the fact that
we have taken your mind off of it in any
way means a lot dude it really does
Community man Community yep and then we
had uh Jake is high one two three in the
chat says tell everyone I said hi so
hello everyone from Jake the beanie bird
with a super chat oh my gosh Ben you
just need to start hating on Badgers
when you stream and the secret chats
Will Roll in because we have another one
here the badgers eat snakes man if you
didn't know this more badger facts
please okay okay I believe you I believe
you I'll make maybe a stream and just
just learning just watch a documentary
you want a 12-page essay after this yeah
Mr snow exactly
enough I kid you not another Super Chat
Ben the badger may be small but mighty
then we had a show time with a super
chat I mean okay now we're getting back
to lore here we go if it's 1890 to 91
and we get a sequel in 92 it can show
albus's childhood with the aftermath of
his father and sister our character
could act as his mentor may not
overshadow us that way that's what I'm
saying everybody knows about what
happened with his pops who got sent to
Azkaban after what he did to uh the
Mogul boys after they they did what they
did to Ariana so like
they're going to be whispering about
Albus yeah when he's there because
everybody knows what's up because he
would have just moved to
um not God is it God just Hollow yeah
right that's where yeah yeah I think
that's what yeah that's what we would
have moved to about around that time so
yeah I I don't know like it depends on
how this game ends that's the big thing
like how does this game end and is it
okay a one-off and it's like okay we're
too powerful so we kind of just go into
the you know ethos and then like the
second one is something completely
different you know like I don't know
like
I don't know if we continue to year six
and seven because what we do is so crazy
they would have to up the I guess the
stakes exactly yeah with each game and
so
I mean yeah you can expand it and maybe
it's affecting the entire Wizarding
World and not just Hogwarts but I don't
have to see him try I'd like to see what
they would come up with I feel like it
could they it could it could go either
way one as completely continuing just
whatever happened prior to this or take
if we have different endings it could
they choose one okay the majority
because they will track what how people
are playing so they'll see this is the
majority of right people like or take
but the second one could be kind of like
with Zelda that you know link there
there are many links in the future
Avatar they can go into a completely
different time frame but still use the
same lore and plot that they've
established here and based on that but
different character it's still you in a
different time it's like the Avatar the
link you know the chosen one but in a
different time zone or different School
but if yeah yeah great options here's
one we could all answer
um Jamie says I have a question how is
flying my sister is dyslexic I got her
game for PS5 she can't play games like
GTA because of the driving
I'll be right back guys I'll be right
back yeah yeah
Lynette you wanna you wanna take that
one on the flying fly wait what's the
specific about playing like I guess just
like how it controls I mean I know they
have like the inverted options they have
you can switch inverted yeah yeah so uh
Jeff my partner and I actually when we
share a game like we we usually have to
switch the controls for him so when I
played it it didn't feel like I needed
to adjust any settings but if he played
it like I'm pretty sure we would have to
go into the settings and invert it or do
something to it
um flying was very interesting to me
because
um so yes I was pretty jerky with it but
I already had my explanation I'm a PC
Gamer I don't use controllers don't come
at me but
um and even actually Chandler can vouch
for this I asked out loud I was like how
long did it take y'all to get used to
flying in the controls and he was
literally like I don't know a minute
okay okay but but part of me was
wondering whether there we know that
there were upgrades mentioned for our
room so part of me was wondering like
well maybe like well first of all I
think it's cool that if the resistance
was intentional which it did seem like
it was then that's really epic
um and two if there's opportunities to
upgrade to perhaps feel like there's
more control or I don't know what the
upgrades might be but that could also
contribute to the feel of the flying but
regardless I'm just gonna have to
practice because I I'm bad at flying in
or in any kind of situation with games
Lego Harry Potter is it's impossible
like when I try to do those games
granted it's chaos because you're
basically breaking everything I'm just
not good at flying and this is also in
part why uh unpopular opinion I don't
really care that there's no quidditch
but that's just me okay oh next person
Miranda how about you how did you feel
about the the flying controls
um you know nothing felt weird to me
actually I I
um
I thought it was very smooth nothing I
didn't notice anything like inverted or
sometimes with flying and stuff they
will invert controls I personally didn't
feel the need to assuming that those
would be default like I didn't think
that I would have to go in and change
anything for myself yeah um I ran into a
lot of things but that's that's also a
me problem I think I went through like
every Archway and every hole that I
could every door frame so that was
exciting but um yeah I mean it
definitely feels like it feels how it
would if you were actually riding one
like you're not kind of what what you
were saying retro when you were um
testing the game you would kind of go
and jerk in different directions like I
was kind of doing the same thing to see
how it would feel and there is like that
you know like you when you go to turn
it's not like an immediate turn you do
feel like you kind of have to slow down
and then kind of divert you know your
direction and go a different way
um it felt really cool but
I don't I didn't see any buttons for
this did do you think we'll ever be able
to do like tricks yeah I was wanting to
go on Victor Crum on like the like you
think about you know backwards and like
handstands on like yeah I don't know
like different we know there's upgrades
maybe yeah I don't know that was
something
yeah yeah like two flips in the air and
like you know you could totally do like
the Slime spins and stuff yeah I think
it was in the second showcase When Alan
was talking to Ben about they didn't
want it to feel like a modern broom like
a fire yeah I know yeah and so that that
for a little bit that caught me off
guard at first because I was like oh
this feels like a little sluggish like
it's controlling I think how it's
supposed to control but it's not super
precise and that's just when you're
sitting there you know you hop on the
Broom exactly you're not holding R2 or
anything when you hold R2 or right
trigger on Xbox like you get kind of
this little speed boost and again I
don't know I'm assuming our broom was
like the level one broom I don't think
it was upgraded yeah and when that when
you do that you get a little bit more
speed and I felt it was a little bit
more precise so I'm thinking by the end
of the game it's going to feel pretty
pretty precise but to the question about
like
they've already announced a ton of
accessibility options which is just I
mean games across the industry have made
some great strides on that uh Dr sherbet
asks so our character can see a thestral
how well I think the game needs to
answer that right I mean that was such a
big part of Harry's Journey yeah yeah
definitely a question I feel like we
should be asking and one that I think
they'll answer in the game uh L win with
a super chat all the creators we know
it's been many sleepless nights away
from family non-stop work to bring us
all this content and build this
community we wouldn't be here without
you we love you all thank you Elwyn
Ellen always showing love to always
Hogwarts Legacy creators thank you
I think she's a mod for you too James is
she a mod for you yet Lynette yeah oh
not yet
no I was making my list last night
because she's fairly busy was I know
this is why I feel bad as I please share
a lot of mods so yeah
yeah
I will come for you literally I've just
be nice to them Elwyn happened
and then like Nico happened
and both came from retro I think or I
can't remember I know Nico for sure Owen
elwin was with I can't remember where I
met no one first if it was in your
stream or mine because all of the mods
on like our my streams and wizing
Wednesdays we're all from Wizards unite
like all right right so like I think
Elwyn Merlin himself Stargazer Tim and
even Nico are like the new ones who are
coming from Ohio's Legacy Community so
um to be a mod like I have to trust you
I have to know you and like you know you
have to kind of uh showcase that vibe
that we as a channel was trying to put
out there and so
um Nico for sure came by requests from
Elwyn but Stargazer Tim and uh elwin we
just clicked and stuff so uh it's good
to see her just be active everywhere and
it's one of those people like a Stephen
like a Cindy who's just everywhere and
everybody's yeah it's just like I think
I've seen both of them here tonight yeah
yeah I know I saw Tim here earlier as
well yeah I was telling them too I was
like guys when the game comes out like
exactly yeah don't feel like you have to
be here because I know you want to play
and experience it too please like yes
you do not have to be here every time
I'm streaming the game yeah uh let's see
we had um oh my goodness all the Hold On
Let's see we had Renee Nicholas full
mail question mark a quest in a book
still alive
It's gotta be alive right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah because I mean this is
only what 40 years before Fantastic
Beasts I want to say May maybe even
longer six years about we don't know the
specific date sure it's true the tasty
Beast was like in the 20s 1920s so yeah
yeah at least 30 years so yeah time
frame yeah see I think a lot of those
like Flamel type characters like like
the ghost you know they they could be
Side characters in the background maybe
Flamel is mentioned but I can't see him
factoring as a major part of the story
not at all that's just me
uh we still certainly have connections
and nods to the things that we're
familiar with yes the world you know
Cloud Rock said I hope it's Mass Effect
style keep the main character oh like I
thought when we were talking about a
sequel earlier yeah that'd be cool if
you got to like carry your character on
to the next one uh dream and play us
that I think that there will be certain
missions that take you to places such as
Azkaban and Gringotts that will be
available based on which house you
choose okay that's an interesting
wrinkle to it right there so I think
Gringotts for sure I mean in the trailer
you can see when they're in that little
portal area they can kind of see through
and I mean it and we see like the little
cart it pretty clearly looks like yeah
yeah Azkaban
you guys think reveal trailer I don't
know
and the poster I mean they're Dementors
so so yeah yeah
all right
where are you James yes the clock
yeah he's off the clock
Spill the Beans you can always like do a
little cryptic message hold on James
said no you say no to mentors no Azkaban
both both oh man what that'd be crazy if
they are if they're on the box of the I
know dark I like I think I think best
case scenario would be like a cut scene
or something because like everybody
forgets how the mentors were like
outside of Azkaban they were summoned by
the ministry so like
okay is there something that would cause
the ministry to bring in Dementors when
you have us who can use Ancient magic
and take down like just about anybody so
like I don't know if it would feel like
a repeat
um it'll feel like a repeat honestly so
we would we would either have to see a
cut scene or they would tread water and
repeat something that we saw and what uh
the fifth movie fifth book where the um
they were around so I don't know because
your theory in one of your videos was
that the covers are the endings the two
endings yes yes the possible endings
yeah yeah that would be kind of cool
yeah I I agree with that because at
least for the original
um cover with the dragonfly into and how
the revealed trailer ends dragonfly
towards the Hogwarts that's the
beginning of Battle of Hogwarts and then
get into the end that's whole my whole
Theory uh base of around that but uh
that's actually it could be cool yeah
like that's the ending and you also have
the mentors on our side but
I feel like we're still gonna see
somehow I hope the Azkaban and the
Dementors but like as I I agree it's a
cutscene like not interactive boy even
for those who I kept thinking about like
expect to patronum as a spell Harry
learned it only because he got because
Dementors uh came close to the school
there's it's a very Advanced magic it
took him any lessons to to nail it so
um like students don't learn that spell
that's why everyone else was like oh yo
Harry you know expect a patronum that's
why he was touching it right yeah yeah
so that's not like every student exactly
exactly right I'm really into so uh we
don't know anything we talked about I
don't know if we talked about this last
night or I'd say I know it's all running
together all the time uh we don't know
much about the The Narrative uh the
story or how it's going to be how we're
interacting with it
um so I think like in terms of I've been
like team pensive for a while now of
like using that as a device for
storytelling
um so perhaps not even like we literally
go to Azkaban but we see somebody's
memory yeah and I think that would be a
fun way to incorporate something that
already exists in The Wizarding World
and expanding the world of Hogwarts
Legacy and having that tie in with
whatever we're exploring with this story
and it's the easy way it's the easy way
to give us stuff yeah yeah without even
creating doing anything yep right yeah
yeah they could just be like yo you want
to see the founders boom offensive yo
you want to see how Hogwarts are sworn
boom you know the previous boom pencil
exactly they can just do everything
through there because like I know
I think Lynette and I put out the same
video like at the same time
and because we had we had actually made
the video the week before but then
Hogwarts actually posted something and
then the book covered that thing because
that's like the the news like cycle
right you just gotta put out the content
when it's topical yeah and then all of a
sudden I think it was a Monday we both
it was a Monday and I was just like wow
we didn't talk about it at all no we did
we did you guys had no idea that you
both were doing it so wow that's
wavelength yeah yeah well James on last
night's stream we learned that Miranda
and Lynette are just like way too
seriously similar yeah so many of the
conversations
I'm not surprised so we had uh Roger
rules yes oh yeah yes very much so Roger
asked is there going to be a preload for
the game next week for launch I think
you can preload now I mean I don't know
okay yeah yeah and then it'll it'll
start the download like usually they do
like a couple days before real quick
yeah yep and then we had another Super
Chat from am there's Whispers the
Sorting Hat may take your early game
choices into account does that possibly
sway your house choice is interesting
I'm not sure if I'm following there like
like you don't actually get sword at the
very beginning but it's gonna take
oh I don't know I think I'll stick with
what I got on Wizarding World regardless
of what right but that would be kind of
a cool way to do it if it's like you
don't get a pop-up quiz you have some
choices maybe making the early game and
then it then it sorts you based on that
I know with uh Magic awakened
um I played the beta like three or four
times and oh yeah they'll they'll like
pick one for you so you'll go through
the process there's a song and stuff
like that and you know you hear the
Sorting Hat talking like blah blah blah
blah blah
um Lynette is Gryffindor and then
you know are you okay we'll ask you are
you okay with this is there a house you
want to be a part of and then I know I
remember that okay so yeah I think I
have a feeling we might get something
along those lines especially with the
integration of Wizarding World so that
sounds right yeah
all right we had uh let's see Jon Snow
rules with a super chat excited to enter
the Forbidden Forest yes I think that's
gonna be
very very creepy
I have had so many people ask me well I
shouldn't say so many but way more than
you would think ask do you think there's
gonna be
um what's it called yes to like turn it
on well because grounded was one of the
first games that I ever played that
actually offered that because in that
game you're like shrunk down and you're
you have these giant bugs like all
around you and so there's a mode
specifically for that
yeah I was gonna say I've never turned
it not I mean I don't know I I don't
know what it looks like I want to know
so like ridiculous it just turns it into
something that's funny you know I think
like a circle and like a rectangle it
doesn't even look like a spider I don't
know I think it's like it takes because
you know archnophobia calms there are
certain elements that the person
identifies in a thing that causes the
fear so necessarily the whole spider but
maybe the amount of lakes or the way
they move so fast or something saying so
maybe it's they kind of
yeah multiple chats are saying it turns
them into blobs
I mean if that counts for someone bear
like have more fun in the game sure
yeah I haven't heard anything though
like if they're uh if they're doing that
or not so Christy said just wanted to
say how much I appreciate you all
everything you do it's a lot of work we
appreciate all the updates and efforts
thank you Christy thank you appreciate
you and then we had Carlo again I think
the main theme is ancient magic that is
why I think no Patronus as that
overshadows ancient magic ancient magic
may defeat the mentors exactly
exactly that's a good point exactly I
mean we just explode people so I can't I
don't see why not it reacts deliberately
according to the enemy so yeah yep and
then Draco Dementors won't come anywhere
near Hogwarts as long as dark poppy is
around oh my gosh
okay this machine
[Laughter]
Ben no we can't trust you anymore
Hufflepuff to Gryffindor talking about
the badger our mascot and agree that
Poppy is not sweet
we can't trust you anymore Bobby is a
saint after the gameplay that all of us
played we saw how sweet she was she was
amazed by the fire burning the Death
Eaters she was it was amazing to see a
dragon in the first place not because of
the violence and then we see her with
high Wing last night with sci-fi like
come on out is she evil she is insane
it's not evil I'm not saying she's evil
anymore Miranda's like I haven't seen
this side of James therefore there's
something to her she's not that 100
sweet because she didn't even lie to her
friend about where she she's going she's
like oh don't tell her and I asked her
like why Grand her grandmother yeah
they're suspicious yeah she's sus Jesus
she's not sweet isn't sweet like in her
last name sweetie that exactly
who hasn't lied to their parent or
grandparents like I don't understand oh
yeah hey yo y'all act like y'all perfect
and toppable Tom Riddle now
my thing with poppy is for wizards unite
players costume stickers gosh oh my God
you know James there's a potential
there's a possibility there's a zero
there's not a zero percent possibility
yeah oh that does make me think okay
good question though in virtually every
Potter book there is always a Twist
there's a character you think that's
like you know
do you think we get a Twist like that in
the game because when if when they first
showed Pig everybody's like fig He's the
bad one and then they they introduced
this like very sweet story about it
I think for sure Miranda okay oh yeah oh
yeah yep
very adamant I think so yes
were you saying baby that's the question
who I yeah oh who yeah I don't know yet
but I have a feeling I have a feeling
that's all I got though but if they
wanted to get like I I still say the
most shocking one would not be poppy I
think it would be Weasley exactly
because we already have such a history
of trusting the Weasley family exactly
Miranda's like we have she's a
Gryffindor she's this Deputy head missed
everyone refers to her not the actual
Headmaster
we've got pressure yeah I could
definitely see that though because yeah
throughout the books and like the movies
there's always some sort of like little
twister deception that ends up clearing
up afterwards there's literally like a
giant deception just throughout the
whole thing that we re or there's
something that we don't see until like
the very end that makes you think
totally different things about one
specific character and you you end up
feeling like you lived a lie the whole
time I'm not projecting not at all but I
I think also that big twist can be also
about us yes like not anyone else but us
even though we play ourselves like our
character but as a part of the story
it's in the end something happens like
wait what what did we do that's who we
are that's who we're played that is what
the Legacy that will leave us because
wasn't it the rumor was it was
originally called Dark Legacy or exactly
yeah yes yes yes so it's us it's
actually us who are the teams that's who
we are a little messed up you know and
there's the reason that no one remembers
about us orange and Magic I just have
that Taylor Swift song stuck in my head
about like I'm the problem it's me yeah
you know what it's deep it's that out
no no no no they can't they have
powerful magic
even the ancient magic Hannah with a
good point here it's interesting because
Harry couldn't cast the unforgivables
but our character can that makes them
pretty powerful that's right he tried
and failed a couple times that is true
uh Carlo would also be cool if they used
a pensive animation when we replay
missions like reliving a memory oh my
god
oh yes I love that that would be kind of
like in in Goblet of Fire because they
use defensive a lot they just bruised me
memories
they did a circle in there they just
made everything level based yeah uh
slime I want to know if you guys can do
a live reaction of the intro of the game
and do an appreciation video for the
team at Avalanche something nice for
them oh that's a good idea that's a cool
idea
yeah yeah live I mean I think you're
gonna be getting so many reactions from
all of us yeah you just bring it all
together I think somebody can just clip
all of the reactions together and just
have the focal scene in the Middle with
all of us around all of us yeah
different ways at the same thing I think
so that's that's a good uh segue to what
are your guys's plans for launch like I
think most of us are streaming I know
Miranda are you gonna do like are you
gonna do the record all your Let's Plays
are you planning on doing any live
streams for Hogwarts
um I tend to like to use like
pre-recorded content and like let's
plays to really focus on the story I
have a very hard time with multitasking
when there's a chat like sometimes like
I don't know which one to focus on so to
like give the story The Respect deserves
and to be able to hang on to everything
I really like to use
um pre-records for that so that's
probably what I'll be doing like day one
I will be hibernating in my room nobody
talked to me that this is it but you are
gonna record you're gonna be recording
your playthrough nice yes for sure and
then I think like because I do want to
go for the Platinum oh yeah I what I
tend to do is like I'll run through the
story on like a recording and then
um once I'm done with the main story
then I'll go platinum and we can like
kind of all hang out as a community and
do that together and get pointers and
stuff so nice I know we're all planning
multiple playthroughs so you can do your
evil Ravenclaw or whatever you choose
this is a long haul this is a long
alcohol deal like like I said yesterday
at least eight playthroughs we need one
for every house we need like a good and
a bad oh yeah for each one so yeah how
about you Ben you're live streaming it
right yeah it's gonna be a little launch
I'm I'm gonna have a lot of fun yeah I
know we're gonna be swimming at the same
simultaneously yeah
uh and then play the game for a little
bit but then I just we can hand it
because I'm sure people will want to
play the game as well but yeah there's a
lot of plans there's gonna be like live
streams but where it's just more
altogether discovering everything but
then there will be also pre-recorded
stuff yeah coming out simultaneously in
a different house like I wanna so it's
there's gonna be a lot there's a lot of
we're starting to work on the schedule
what's it go I know dude right people
think there's a lot of content now about
Hogwarts I'm just like just waiting
this is sweet yeah yeah James how about
you Wizarding Wednesdays yeah
yeah for the foreseeable future for you
know at least the next two weeks at
least
um we'll be streaming it
um that's what that's what the community
has asked like they want to see they for
some reason they enjoy all of our
reactions and stuff and I know if Merlin
pops on the screen they want to be a
part of that experience or if he does
that you know we need your reaction yeah
yeah so you know kind of filming myself
reacting differently I think would be
different if I was just like isolated
like Miranda but if I'm doing it live
and you see them yeah if I if that
happens like you're going to see a
completely different James like just
jumping into his chair like just
throwing stuff around just like I
words it's just going to be like Blurry
yeah so uh yeah live streaming this for
sure uh with some
Let's Plays just cutting them down into
a digestible content for those who
weren't a part of it for uh the live
streams and then uh maybe sprinkling
some tips and tricks but
um I'm trying to enjoy this game this is
a game we've all been waiting for for 20
some odd years man
um we all are content creators and we
need to you know make sure we have
content for the channel but at the same
time I'm going to be a fan first for
this and enjoy every second and
hopefully with the community so yeah
that's the plan so far Monette how about
you
yeah so
um okay I'm a nerd so I have the if
you've ever taken Clifton strengths like
there's like list of these attributes
that are your strings that you play to
so mine are like intellectual input uh
ideation so I'm bringing this up because
I'm bringing this up because I work best
when I like
uh play around and like I've like what's
the right word I I simmer on like trying
to make connections of like I I'm gonna
display my full playthrough anytime I
play Hogwarts Legacy it's going to be
live unless I need to like go back and
be like oh wait I I didn't I don't want
to show off like how I died 50 times in
combat let me like actually get a good
clip for a video but for the most part
my entire Hogwarts Legacy uh experience
will be live streamed on the internet so
um launch week is a little like chaotic
because everyone's gonna be trying to
multitask right so like making
connections making content so
um not that first week of launch but the
second week of launch will be a very
regular schedule
um where I'll be streaming Monday
through Friday on YouTube so Monday
Wednesday Friday I'll do my normal
morning when I'm calling my morning
Stream So usual coffee chat time I think
I'm doing a little bit earlier and kind
of going into the afternoon for me my
time and then Tuesday Thursday I'm gonna
hit evening for people that after work
or whatever time and of course all of
these vods are going to be on YouTube so
that you can re-watch the stream if you
miss it like don't yeah they're all
going to be doing YouTube it sounds like
yeah yeah and then I'll have a special
Saturday stream that y'all will have to
stay tuned for the details there may or
may not be Bellatrix cosplay I'm just
saying oh
oh
shout out okay so Nico I think we missed
a message from Chandler sounds like this
one is directed specifically at James he
said I don't know did you see Poppy's
smile at the end of the quest you all
played I did
okay again I acknowledged that and said
she was just amazed by seeing a dragon
we don't know if this is her first time
seeing a dragon used fire she loves
animals again yes yes yeah and she hates
poachers
people
chill chill with my girl man leave my
girl alone all right let's do some we're
gonna do some rapid fire
I do I do have a point yet no yeah I
know I know you you yes so um about that
mission in general I just want to say
that Carlos he's he's um
he's not into Harry Potter he but he
loves stories and actually when I was
showing and editing stuff I showed him
that part he's like I like it it's like
I'm following the story I'm invested he
he cared about the creatures and like he
felt on the same side with poppy
actually so you know he didn't really
know much about her but he was like you
know the storyline so that's just a
little nice little little something that
I got a non-really Harry Potter guy
that's awesome I like this that's
awesome that's cool that's awesome great
I think of all of us here Lynette may be
the only one who can answer this I'm not
really a PC player they asked info on PC
performance and if dunevo might affect
I've seen a lot of people in comments
talking about this dunevo donovo thing I
have no idea what it is I don't know
what that is either also just keep in
mind all of us when we previewed played
on the PS5 so I still have no idea in
terms of PC for Hogwarts like see well
like for um for steam since you can
purchase it on Steam correct I think
mostly like most games at the very
bottom they will give they will give you
like a list of all the recommended PC
specs that is recommended for that
specific game I know I I do reference
those a lot for my PC yeah
um whenever I'm buying a game I do look
at that so okay all right we had Matt
maybe you choose between doubling down
on the dark arts or a corporeal Patronus
there needs to be an alternate option to
the unforgivable curses also love you
all and the community yeah I've thought
about that a lot too because it's like
there's not really in the Harry Potter
Wizarding World it's not like light and
dark magic you know even you have the
unforgivables which yeah those three are
bad but everything else it's just like
it's like how you use it and even I
always say even with Patronus even
Umbridge could cast a Patronus so it's
not
doesn't if you're evil you could still
cast Patronus I guess if you can come up
here
it's just really bad
people I won't fight anybody on that
because there is a story of the person
in one of the most evil cats who tried
to do it and like it turned into maggots
I've got his name and like devour with
him so
Umbridge is the exception not the rule
not the rule so maybe she like in her
past maybe she did have some true
legit she was doing it all for the
ministry initially anyway yeah or or
it's a plot haul yeah
but overall I agree that that evilness
goodness I agree with magic specifically
dark magic whatever like it's it's a
spectrum it's not like it defines you
exactly how do you do it it's not a
person though like what if it's a
corrupted Patronus what if it's
something that we don't know of oh
is it versus a charm separate like I
think you're yeah curses curses are bad
charms are like listen okay I'm not
convinced that we actually know the true
nature of magic okay so this is also
this is weird
last night I
pulled out my education card I'm gonna
pull it out again a little bit it's just
like thinking about knowledge like and
how we know magic or what it is like I'm
gonna throw a big word sorry I'm not
trying to be pretentious let's do it
epistemologically that's not like
knowing and then ontologically is like
what is and so the nature of Magic the
fact that we we Collective Wizarding
World still don't understand ancient
magic in Harry Potter's time and I'm
gonna assume modern day Wizarding World
with Harry Potter Wizards unite makes it
kind of wild to me you have a school and
you have magic is this thing and you try
to organize it to make sense of it so we
have classes that are like
Transfiguration charms and you have the
broader categories of like charms hexes
and whatever but those are just people
ascribing a label to it it might not be
that clean cut or it could be organized
or labeled in a different way that maybe
maybe that's the secret that the
Wizarding World kept hidden is this
corrupt did Magic I don't know that's
just then and then I think about spells
like sectum sympra that Snape invented
which is like literally just that I find
someone is so interesting so interesting
like you can possibly invent it like
nothing is totally black and white
making me rethink it James no it all
depends on the origin of magic which I
think we're gonna get a little bit into
with uh with ancient magic and the story
that is called Hogwarts Legacy because I
mean I keep hammering back Hogwarts
Legacy Legacy something that's passed
down given to you know from a
predecessor as whatever and so I think
we're going to get into what is how
either Hogwarts started or our origin
and what that turns into with our
involvement in this story whether it's
ancient magic magic overall or Hogwarts
or our descendants so I think it's just
going to have to boil down to what magic
means to The Wizarding World and how
it's used overall but in regards to like
good and bad there's curses and there's
charms now it may be mislabeled like
Lynette is breaking down or whatever but
yo Canon lower wise guys there's curses
there's charms charms and curses yo they
are different they're the same they are
different yes yes but they still don't
Define you as good or evil whether you
use it or not they don't they don't they
don't they don't it's just being witches
we're kind of messed up the Wizards and
witches
I mean to be fair Hogwarts is a
dangerous place yeah all right let's do
I'm realizing we are way behind on chat
so and we're running actually I think I
we're getting close to end of time so
I'm gonna go through let's do some rapid
fire we'll just do like one question per
person we'll start with Lynette so Pete
asks will it break your immersion if
using the unforgivable spells doesn't
change the way the game's story plays
out
um I think you know there's a lot of
things that I think I'll be fine with
just I'm being real honest here like
this is based on what we've seen like
I'm I mean even minor things where I
can't land everywhere like I'll get over
it it's fine I think that uh it would be
cool but I I'm also fine just treating
it as a mechanic of like hey this is
this is epic
uh Renee thank you for the super chat
we'll get we'll toss this one to James
what will your overall aesthetic be in
game uh one color beasts mainly potions
I shall be a girly Ravenclaw who loves
potions nice awesome thank you it'll
depend yo honestly with so much drip in
this game man like yo your boy is going
to be changing his outfit
yeah the cape alone I'm like yo I need
that joint in Hufflepuff yellow
um so yeah it's just going to be based
off the day but you know my overall
theme is just going to be
um imagine zoologists Hufflepuff like
I'm new to my boy like that's what's
that's the vibe I'm going for all right
Ben here's my biggest question this is
from cloud Roth why haven't we heard of
our character before if they're so
special
because we never our magic never
surfaced the like we literally we were
thought to be a muggle or whatever or so
only until recent time
gotcha okay
Joe just said welcome to the dark side
bin poppy for dark lord I mean I did
create one of the I did Photoshop one of
the pictures of her being looking evil a
m said poppy cells
gosh probably sells High Wing to the
poachers confirmed oh my gosh okay okay
yeah I'm staying out of this Chris said
this time next week we will be playing
Legacy thank you all for creating great
content great to see all your beautiful
faces yo I don't know I think this is
legit Benjamin B with a super chat I was
a Dev on the game I'm looking forward to
people discovering the wonders of the
southern region that hedge Arch under
the windmill and the Merlin puzzles
write that down write it down
this is like frantically uh Jeremiah hot
take the shocking enemy Professor garlic
that would be a pretty big surprise too
uh Carlo combat is inspired by the
Arkham games I think so is the alohomora
could be yeah it could be
uh let's see
we'll be spending a lot of time watching
all your gameplay reactions please do do
this again oh yeah we're gonna do we'll
definitely have to do this again once
all the we've all had time to experience
experience the game
uh let's see Sentai said love your all
vids and expecto gautroneum
nice uh Morgan from old oak again said
legit though the poacher's using AK on
the owl that hurts my heart right that
was messed up they just messed up
uh Chris said poppy hates poachers
because she's jealous of them no okay
okay so that part I'm not part of I
still you know
Christy said love how the ad to get back
on his legacy's trailer oh wait like the
ad for the video no way yeah yeah yeah
epic uh Jamie said no spells are bad
it's the intent okay
and I think we're caught up now I think
we're caught up nice hey you guys follow
the questions
all right so if you guys have any other
final questions here you can just post
them in the chat but um I just want to
say thank you all to joining me for this
I know this is like a super busy week
for all of us as we ramp up to what is
going to be an insane week after all
this time as I titled the stream tonight
it's been it's been quite a ride so
yeah I'm trying to make sure I'm not
forgetting anything that I wanted to to
bring up tonight so any any final
thoughts I think you guys um
yeah we've all already talked about
where we're going to be playing the game
next week you can find us all on YouTube
Let's see we had one more that just came
through oh a 10 10 gifted memberships
from Lord Star-Lord Kirby thank you very
much
[Music]
uh I'll just say uh going way way back
about thinking about the launch trailer
I yeah
I keep saying and you all know this some
of y'all saw me live react in person to
that cinematic trailer like I just can't
even every time they post something it's
so well done I think I I basically died
at the cinematic trailer because it was
the way that it was put together the
Thematic elements of having the eyes of
the owl opening and The Eyes Of Us
closing it and just like the way that
it's swooped and like it totally just
blew me away and the end with the the
silent drop into our hands going into
hedwig's theme gave me literal chills
yeah so I I don't even know how I'm
going to exist tomorrow because I every
time they just completely go like more
and more above and beyond so I'm very
much looking for it you think it's
tomorrow I think it's tomorrow like I
started today
you know why would they they didn't
mention it they did mention it in in one
of the Wizarding Wednesdays prior to
that if you go there they're like oh
look out for something on next on the
first and there was something about a
PlayStation checklist I saw somewhere
yeah it said watch a trailer
something something something yeah yep
yeah it was either Wednesday or Thursday
for that PlayStation okay
um but I think wizzy Wednesdays because
the perfect day it's a thing they're
doing
um even though we're doing it yeah but
um
no yeah I I think tomorrow I think
tomorrow well if it drops tomorrow guys
you can head over to Wizarding Wednesday
on expecto ghost stream yes yeah what
time James um four we're back on
schedule 4 30 Eastern uh so nice and
Lynette are you doing a morning stream
tomorrow
see how you feel like well yes if
there's something I think at this point
I am just like backlogged with uh
content ideas and wrap-up things so that
at this point I think it would be easier
for me to just live react and you can
just consume it and chat with me about
it yeah Ben how about you what's your
next big thing I know you got a couple
more
things lined up this week
um yeah well we'll see I don't know
In This Moment follow him on uh Twitter
there you go yeah no I'll keep you
updated I'm just like kind of realizing
that you know theories this is it yeah
yeah this is real home stress NYX like
yeah this is the last time what we're
gonna see tomorrow we're gonna see the
trailer we have to cherish those moments
because this last time we're going to be
theorizing until until we played the
game fully then we'll theorize about the
second one yeah maybe I did not gonna
happen for a while yeah yeah how about
you Miranda what's your next you got any
big any big videos planned we already
teased the the Sorting one he got that
one coming up soon oh yeah yeah
like the resorting taking the quiz
against you which house I get like I get
put into because I want it to be as
authentic to myself the first place I
can because I want to be the one Walking
The Halls so but otherwise I really
don't have anything planned I very much
operate through improv I really just
like to be inspired in the moment like
if if something comes to my mind and I'm
like I really need to make a video on
this like now that's what I will have my
focus set on that's just always how I
operate so
um and if anything does drop you can bet
that I will be like live tweeting it in
all caps like you'll be able to hear
your phone so that's kind of also what I
do a lot
I apologize but yeah I don't know just
whatever happens happens I will be
waiting and watching for all of it
though and what's your Twitter handle
again is it the in the Twitter no
somebody took the Miranda Lauren or is
they took Miranda Lori and so I am
Miranda lorians with an S gotcha yeah by
the way I remembered I am making a video
about a fire tornado I had to I got you
because I so love it but are you gonna
say how you want to eat it I did I did I
did I did put it in the reason why I
said it in yours because I had already
recorded
yes but yeah I'm I'm been snow in on
Twitter and I think no I'm Benjamin Snow
on YouTube oh that's that actually made
me just think though something I didn't
know we all want to mention is guys I
don't know if it's the Hogwarts Legacy
Community as a whole but all of our
channels have been getting hit by these
spam there's somebody pretending to be
Ben like made a whole new account so any
of these telegrams message me I've
gotten two people emailing me saying did
I win something it's we're trying to
block them we're trying to hide them
we're doing everything we can but if
yeah yeah make sure if you see them that
you on YouTube you can report but
anything that we do you guys would I
mean you know where our official places
are I would not respond to you in a
YouTube comment I don't think any of
these creators here would either give it
away
yeah yeah
no bashing or anything like that either
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah they're
everywhere but unfortunate yeah yeah
and then we had a few last minute super
chats Blue Moon just says horsey with
exclamation points
mercs that have been a Hufflepuff since
2011 and retake the test in preparation
for the game and I keep getting
Gryffindor all right I guess I don't
know that's your pride let's go and then
we'll do Miranda didn't get to answer a
question we'll toss the last one to her
uh Immortal said what if the mentors act
like Mr X from Resident Evil an enemy
you can't fight but can only run oh my
oh gosh
well I hate cardio so running is out of
the question I'm just gonna go find a
corner sit in the fetal position
you thought about that kind of idea
though because we've all been thinking
you can't fight them without
the Patronus so you just you run yeah
for them a birdie Bots every flavored
Bean like would you like to try this oh
so flavored Bean right here for you
eat chocolate it'll help
yeah well guys thank you so much for
joining me this has been a blast uh
hopefully the first of many and like
like been said I mean this is this is it
for all your theories
pre-pre-launch at least on my channel
you know check out James tomorrow uh
Lynette if she's streaming as well but
um man thank you all so much for the
journey that's what I really just wanted
to stream tonight to be one where we got
to reflect look back on this crazy two
two and a half three years however long
it's been I've lost lost count now
because it's been uh it's been epic so
you guys can find me of course right
here we're watching now I will be
streaming live next Monday we're gonna
do a countdown uh like Ben like James uh
like Lynette too
so if you got like the you know you
could set up your multiple windows have
a saw go and have the chat going and
we'd love to see you there but check out
all these folks they're awesome do
amazing work work really really hard on
making videos for you guys
um but yeah thank you all so much
and I'll talk to you again soon bye
everyone oh yeah the ones
oh I didn't get the memo I didn't last
night James
I had to go and grab mine all right you
all have a good night thank you guys see
ya